kids are also dying of heart attacks at
an increasing rate CBS covered that hot
act deaths have become more across all
age groups since the start of the corona
buyer
but a recent study found that young
people are actually most at risk in this
case according to Cedar Sinai Hospital
the number of heart attack deaths among
25 to 44 year olds in the U.S over the
first two years of the pandemic was 30
percent higher than predicted Dr Celine
gander is here on set with us to talk
more about it she's at large for public
health at Kaiser health news and she is
also an infectious disease specialist
and epidemiologist and a CBS News
medical contributor Dr Gander thank you
for being here what stood out to you in
this study I think the fact that you're
seeing such a big increase specifically
in the youngest age group so the 25 to
44 year old you saw this 30 increase in
the risk of death from heart attack and
that really is quite striking that's not
a group an age group in which you
normally see heart attacks much less
dying from a heart attack so to do a
study like this you look at the years
prior to the pandemic and the typical
rate of heart attack death in that age
group and then you see it increase and
you wonder what's the new variable and
so the pandemic is that new variable
that's right so these uh researchers
looked at 10 years of data across the
U.S all the death certificates that get
filed with the CDC that data and so what
they saw is prior to the pandemic heart
attack deaths were actually dropping and
then that Trend reverses and you see
those deaths go up especially among that
youngest age group during the pandemic
and do we know why the why younger
people might be more at risk or we don't
know for sure and in fact these death
certificates are probably not even
capturing the fact that they might have
had covid they're really just saying did
you die from a heart attack or not what
we do know however is that younger
people were less likely to protect
themselves against covet than older
people less likely to mask less likely
to take other mitigation measures and
they were also farther back in line to
get vaccinated so they were not
protected with vaccination until later
in the Pandemic those might have been a
factor here so basically I mean you
could have had perhaps a mild infection
and of course this is all hypothetical
but then there might have been a
lingering heart situation hard disease
right so covet causes inflammation of
the blood vessels as well as other parts
of the body and also blood clots and
what we think is that a covenant
infection may have actually accelerated
the process of developing heart disease
what we call coronary artery disease and
so therefore accelerated when somebody
might have had a heart attack and died
from a heart attack you know but covert
also changes how much you you can get
out to an exercise class how often you
see friends maybe your level overall
your stress whether you see your doctor
how are they ruling out or accounting
for these other Lifestyle Changes we
don't know so you can't really assess
that just from looking at death
certificates again all we can say is how
old were they did they die from a heart
attack
um but you know some of the factors
you're mentioning could certainly have
played a role we also know Health Care
Facilities were really overwhelmed
during the pandemic so was it that
somebody had a heart attack and then was
less likely to survive because the
health care facility was overwhelmed
couldn't get there on time well thank
you so much uh something new to to go
and see your doctor and and check
yourself about thank you thank you
what can I tell you
I don't know did we inject a whole bunch
of young people with all sorts of weird
stuff and we didn't know what was going
on
[Music]